you know he's lost some momentum
sometime
i think he might bail out could make an
argument for maybe giving a check i'm
not sure which square exactly when the
white king moves now you can just defend
your bishop maybe oh but he's going for
the draw niche let's go back to the
players i think we're going to see a
result if anish brings his queen back to
the f4 square
then we will see a draw magnus looking
away from the board now
he's pretty confident he saved this game
but aneesh play for the win you won't
get a better chance against the world
champion and he takes the draw ah it is
a draw a dramatic game but a draw in
game two between magnus carlsen and
anish geary still tied both games so far
ended with draws and oh they're actually
we haven't seen that before
discussing the game probably i find that
quite off-putting myself if you know you
you've been winning
and you i'm sure anish is a bit annoyed
with himself because he knew he's
probably winning there and your opponent
suddenly told you when you should have
won he's like where you could have
played this you just won you know why
didn't you do that and then walks off